The Walking Dead's recent seasons have
seen a major turning point in the show
with the arrival of Jeopardy Morgan as
the villain negan who leads the Savior's
and an all-out war against Rick's forces
and Robert Kirkman Robert Kirkman's
Walking Dead comics this is one of the
best most exciting storylines but when
it comes to the adaptation on the show
fans have been less pleased I think we
should break down some of the key
differences between the show and the
comics and I have some questions for you
guys about adaptations in general so you
know hopefully we can like get to the
bottom of what's going on here okay the
first major difference is the overall
presence of negan in the comics negan's
presence looms over everything it really
feels like it's a one-on-one between
negan and Rick but on the show jeopardy
Morgan feels a lot more like a
supporting character he has appeared in
less than half of the episodes in the
past two seasons that's significantly
less than the other series leads who
don't really matter to the plot now this
may be because Jeffrey Dean Morgan is
really a big-time actor he probably
costs a lot more to the network per
episode while Stephen OGG who plays
negan's lieutenant Simon as really kind
of had to fill in as negan second half
he's done a fantastic job but the
tag-teaming has and might been in
resulted in two half measures of good
villains rather than one full measure of
negan that he is in the comics now all
the SANS negan episodes bring us to our
second adaptation difference the new
communities like the scavengers and
Oceanside which really don't play a role
in this stage in the comics the
scavengers is a new creation for the
show now both of these colonies just
come off as places on a map really with
their own quirks rather than real
societies that behave the way real
people would Kirkman established that
world building so well for the hilltop
in the kingdom but at any time i nepo so
descent oceanside in the landfill is
just kind of there's no sense of stakes
now another adaptation issue is the role
Carol and Daryl play on the show as
opposed to in the comics now Daryl isn't
even in the comics but Carol's character
is significantly changed from Kirkman's
version into one of the most badass
characters on TV really now the problem
is because neither of them are a part of
the all-out war storyline in the comics
the show has kind of been forced to
invent new ways for them to participate
which too often has left them inactive
like Daryl spent half a season in a
prison cell Carol spent
full season in a freaking cottage doing
nothing yeah but at least the show
hasn't killed them off right which is
the other major adaptation issue fans
are confused about this season saw the
death of Rick's son Carl which does not
happen in the comics at this point and
in fact Carl goes on to be a very
interesting character in storylines
after this war maybe the show was just
ready to part ways with actor Chandler
Riggs and reassigned that cooler future
storylines to new characters that they
want to create
now while losing fan favorite actors
like Steven Yeun who played Glenn and
Michael Cudlitz who played Abraham that
might have been harder on viewers the
death of Carl really felt like another
departure from the comics that just robs
us of scene the cool guy he would turn
into and another example of the show
slowing down a fast-paced war in the
comics now it's gonna hard to know if
anyone for anyone to know if they're
doing a good job or not including the
people working on the show because yeah
at some point you're just trying you're
trying to figure out exactly what the
audience of the show is is it just the
fans who know the comics is there a
separate fan base which I honestly think
there is if the so many people were
upset by Glenn's death it shows that
there are more people watching this show
than people just read the comics because
yet Glenn does die in the comics it is a
critical turning point there is a
narrative reason for him to die but
people got so attached to Stephen the
unns portrayal of that character and
when he left the show it's something
they did lose something that they have
not replaced yet and I I am one of the
move I think the minority of viewers who
I think Carl's death was justified and I
mean no offense to the actor I think
they can get more interesting characters
I unfortunately I just don't think the
way maybe there was a disconnect between
the writers and Chandler Riggs that just
was not working out and maybe they felt
it too maybe they felt that that actor
was ready to move on and I think they
could take that really cool future Carle
storyline and apply it to Rick's
daughter you know or Enid they won't
because here's the thing again staying
with the per second a successful
comic-book adaptation there's I would
say three major things that that come to
mind about the success of any story in
general but separately you have your
character arc right like what did your
character gonna go through how they can
what are they gonna learn by the end if
your plot arc which is literally what's
gonna happen this story how to keep it
exciting something climactic in the
middle something a satisfying resolution
at the end and then this one element
that I think the Walking Dead TV show
loses all the time and it's just as
simple as the characters want and goals
and that being connected to the other
two things so instead where they take
they'll lift a plot arc they'll stretch
the hell out of it and we'll make it a
season of the TV show even though it's
two issues of the comic stretch the hell
out of it then they'll stretch which is
you would think is a good move a
character arc it's like okay over the
course of this whole season Rick is
gonna learn you know what he does need
other people it's like okay fine that
again they did them to up it to issues
so that might be a lot but fine we want
to see him change so we'll go with you
as long as Rick has an active actual
goal for a whole season that matches
those two things like in you know he's
gonna try to go off on his own and you
know kill every walker or something like
he has like something very specific that
he's gonna try to do and throughout the
course is gonna you know learn about
meeting other people and go through some
sort of plot and that's interesting
instead they do the other two but the
characters feel like they're floating
along in this story and so you could
kind of like but you should never go up
this you can jump in an episode one jump
in a middle up so jump in as a last
episode and you got the whole season
this because you know actually are
they're never succeeding or failing
they're always in limbo right yeah and I
mean to be a bit cynical I think when
you're watching television shows so many
of these problems can just be ignored if
you really nail the villain and jeopardy
Morgan's acting is awesome I love him in
the show but in terms of how much they
use him think of so many other shows
that like our kind of divisive right
maybe like Dexter so many there's a
couple really great seasons of the show
Dexter on Showtime purely because the
villain is incredible Boardwalk Empire a
Bobby Cannavale II played an amazing
character amazing villain I believe a
season three or four there's so many of
these like you know hour-long drama
series yeah and and you can get so much
done by just letting the villain take
over the story for a season and they
have not
you can do that they have not Unchained
him he appears every fourth episode it's
like if anything I mean as much as I
love Geoffrey de Morgan's Stephen OGG
has proven he's such a great character
actor and he is captured that kind of
negan spirit in a way and makes me wish
we could go back in time and just cast
him so that you couldn't afford to put
him in every single episode and let him
be the true lead that negan should be in
this story because it's a bit that's the
reason people love this storyline in the
comics he's such a fun cares on the
cover of so many of those and he has not
been on the cover of most of these
episodes and I think that's I think the
thing that I hopefully going forward
they'll be able to course-correct
maybe it's just a matter of AMC's
shelling out more money to the budget
yeah well what do you think The Walking
Dead could use more of or do you think
the show is fine and maybe some of the
haters out there should just lay off
either way comment down below and a
reminder to you all to subscribe to new
rock stars for all of our recaps
analysis The Walking Dead episodes
thanks everybody